whenever numbers are related to each
other right mathematicians are not
always known for their creativity right
so when you see numbers that are related
to each other particularly if you've got
a pair of numbers we call that very
imaginatively
a relation okay so here's a new word for
you right maybe you can put in a
relation this relation is any connection
between two numbers so for instance our
life is full of numbers right you can
think of for instance the temperature in
the day as the day progresses that's a
number in degrees and the time of the
day like in hours that's also another
and those two numbers are connected they
clearly connected right so that a
relation exists between the two of them
yeah there are all kinds of other things
that are related in the same way for
instance I could say how old you are and
how tall you are those are also two
numbers and clearly they are connected
right so a relation exists between those
two things right but in mathematics
we're interested in some relations more
than others the relations that we call
functions right now before I give you a
technical definition I want to try and
get across to you a vibe for what a
function is okay here's my function does
anyone know what these two symbols are
you know one of them is right what's the
first one
it's dollar sign my shaking money what's
the what's the second one let's comment
its the euro okay so European currency
which is anyway um these two quantities
right let's call it for a sec it's
called Australian dollars and euros
they're two numbers that are connected
to numbers they're not connected right
but importantly if you have a certain
number of Australian dollars you're on a
different number of years didn't even
happen to know what the conversion rate
is roughly even in the ballpark isn't
like if we have one
hey you did does anyone know how much
roughly you'd get about half point six
five let me on me okay stand back you
know let's go with that because because
it sounds it sounds all right now if I
have if I have a dollar
I'll have point six five euros that
means if I have ten dollars I'll have
six and a half years if I have and so on
and so on right now the important thing
is this connection means so these are
not of money that you've got if I know
how much money you've got I know exactly
how many sorry if I know how many Aussie
dollars you've got I know exactly how
many euros you've got does that make
sense right so this uniquely defines
this don't even write that down that's a
really crucial phrase now the reason why
it's crucial is because lots of
relations are not like that
in fact maybe most of them I don't like
that let's think about that um
temperature and time temperature and
time okay if you know what temperature
it is for example outside on a certain
day do you know what time it is just
based off the temperature the answer is
no you don't even if you know like very
actually what's going on suppose I say
you okay 14 degrees fortunately it's pre
chilly right it could be like at 3:00
a.m. or something like that but it could
eat easily be you know 11 p.m. as well a
temperature does it uniquely define a
time right you're not sure which one it
could be what's the other example I gave
agent hunt
agent right if I know your age I still
don't know how how tall you'll be this
incredible variation right it's sitting
in the room and vice versa if I know how
tall you are I feel like yes I'm exactly
168 centimeters tall I'm like hi you're
15 and 0.7 years old no that's rubbish
there's too much there is a connection
right but it's not like this watertight
unique definition okay so this thing
that you see here dollars and euros
right that's what we mean by a function
okay that's what we're talking about
this is the specific kind of
relationship that we're interested in
okay
so therefore
you can write this on proper definition
underneath now you're gonna vie for it a
function is it's a particular kind of a
relation right that uniquely defines and
now I'm gonna be a little more specific
on you again this time do uniquely
defines outputs based on inputs let me
give you one more way to say that same
idea because sometimes when you're
learning a new idea the more ways you
have to say something and understand it
the better so in other words every input
has exactly one output okay so for
instance our language she of using a
function is to say for instance the
number of years you have is a function
of how many Australian dollars you have
can I say that again right the number of
years you have is a function of the
number of trillion dollars that you have
we're gonna write this and we're gonna
use this notation okay so let's call it
I don't know let's call it e for you
right right and D for dollars okay I can
say using these notations that a is a
function also this is a weird
interesting use of brackets that we
haven't really done before we would
usually read that as a times date right
like times whatever's in the brackets
but in this case we mean and I'll write
insanity E is a function of days you
tell me how many dollars you've got I'll
tell you how many euros you've got right
and I'm gonna do it according to this
rule
you tell me
0.65 right so you take the number of
dollars you've got and if you multiply
it by 0.65 that will tell me how many
euros you've got does that make sense so
I'm reading this as euros are a function
of dollars and this is the function
I suppose I could write that with the
number of the front 0.65 dollars times
the number of dollars but you know
multiplication have to change it's no
big deal okay